Ben Tracy is in Beijing with North and
South Korea's newest steps to build on
their historic summit Ben good morning
good morning a lot of heads are still
spinning as Kim jong-un continues this
attempted transformation from dictator
to diplomat now in addition to promising
to close North Korea's main nuclear test
site next month
Kim jong-un also seems to be
acknowledging for the first time that
denuclearization to him
actually means giving up his weapons
according to the South Koreans Kim said
at the summit that if we receive
promises for an end to the war and he's
talking about the Korean War and a
non-aggression treaty then why would we
need to live in difficulty by keeping
our nuclear weapons in a gesture of
goodwill North Korea is now going to
match its time zone to South Korea's
back in 2015 Kim jong-un moved the Norse
clocks back 30 minutes to what became
known as Pyongyang time South Korea says
it's gonna remove the massive
loudspeakers at its border with North
Korea that were used to blast propaganda
and Korean pop music the two countries
say they want to turn the DMZ into what
they are calling a genuine peace zone
now meanwhile China has largely been in
on the sidelines while all this
diplomacy has been happening they're
hoping to get back in the game this week
by sending their top diplomat to North
Korea